good morning john welcome to 2021 new
last video you walked us through what
you thought 2020 was gonna be like
a year ago and how you feel like you did
and i just i have to just
blow you out of the water right now i am
way
way far ahead of you because john when i
was 10
in 1990 i wrote an essay called what i
think
life will be like in the year 2020 and i
would like to read it to you
and then we're going to go over my
historical timeline of what i think is
going to happen
every year from 1990 to the year 2020. i
have been
waiting for this moment for a long time
this is
reason enough to have become a video
blogger john
i think life in 2020 will be really neat
i think there will be cures for almost
every illness and people will be 200
years old
there's a bit of a math problem here if
the oldest person on earth in 1990 was
110 years old they could only be 140.
that's as
that's as old as they can be in 2020
unless we're like bringing people back
to life there will also be alien races
that have brought new technologies to
earth maybe we'll even find ways to make
the oh make the dead alive again
okay so never mind so there will be no
more extinct animals
okay that was a twist i didn't expect
that actually
we kind of have figured out a little bit
of de-extinction work basically i think
life in 2020 will be cool
okay but john i know what you're really
curious about my year by year timeline
of what's going to happen
oh god this actually starts in 1980 so i
did 10 years of stuff that actually
happened like cool man steve mcquinn
dies of cancer who is that steve mcqueen
so the first thing i have 1991 iraq
releases hostages this actually happened
in 1990 but in december so i was close
1992 way of living in space invented the
iss launched in 1998
so not too far off 1993 peace in the
middle east
shoot first community on the moon we
have not got there yet 1995 electric
cars the gm ev1 was released in 1996.
i'm not bragging but i'm bragging follow
quickly in 1996 by go
to mars so unless we're talking about
the pathfinder mission which was in 1997
uh no 1998 100 television stations
without a satellite
this was what i was worried about 1999
not an election year
first black president but we did get
that year 2000 cure for cancer
i'm sure that all cancer was cured in
the year 2000. there's just turns out
there's a lot of cancers little hank i'm
sorry 2002
only three years after the first black
president we had the first woman
president so
something hinky happened here 2004 true
ghost discovered
that didn't happen 2008 oil line breaks
many animals suffer
now i just had to point that one out
because the deepwater horizon was 2010.
so that was kind of close i'm sure there
was also an oil spill in 2008 2009
rainforest lost forever so
i thought life was going to be pretty
cool in 2020 but i thought all the
rainforests were going to be gone so
that's a win 2011. i'm not making this
up
burt reynolds dies of heart condition
burt reynolds died of cardiac arrest
in 2018. i don't know what to say i'm
not
right but i'm not that wrong 2012
superior fish beings
i don't know what they do but they are
there they exist 2016
thousands of aliens come in peace we're
still holding out hope for that and
what was my prediction for the year 2020
john
what was it well i can tell you right
now i got it wrong but i
had every chance of getting it right
garfield turns 80.
like why didn't i just look at when
garfield was born
and then do the math no garfield does
not turn 80 this year garfield turned 42
years old this year
i could have just looked it up and now
john we are headed into the
great unknown the time beyond 2020.
thank you for making stuff with me and
i'll see you on tuesday